today on the matt wall show republican
glenn younkin pulled out a stunning
victory last night we'll talk about the
lessons that can be learned from it and
we'll revel in the hilarious media
meltdown that happened today as well
also the mother of the boy who raped a
girl in loudoun county has finally
spoken out her comments are revealing
but perhaps not in the way she intends
plus the kyle rittenhouse trial kicks
off we'll discuss that and finally is it
cruel and callous for parents to kick
their adult children out of their homes
and force them to live on their own
that's what many people seem to think
and we'll talk about that today and so
much more on the matt welsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
truly in all of my many long hours as a
virginia resident i've never been so
proud ever since i first came out as a
trans virginian i have dreamed of a day
like this my greatest hope now is that
others will be inspired to live their
own truth loudly and boldly and the
truth in virginia last night as you've
heard by now is that republican glenn
younkin did pull out the upset victory
over terry mcauliffe
it wasn't even all that close in the end
with yonkin winning by three or four
points which may as well be a landslide
considering that biden biden won the
state by 10 points a year ago so this
was a massive swing a tectonic shift an
earthquake and especially cataclysmic
for democrats when you consider that the
swing
didn't even happen over the course of an
entire year or half a year
only a couple of months ago yunkin was
down significantly in the polls and
running a standard default
gop beltway type campaign
then things changed
and we'll talk about those changes and
what they mean but before we do that
before we discuss the reality on the
ground let's check in with mcauliffe's
pr team in the corporate media who are
all as expected not taking this very
well the good news for republicans is
that the democrats are steadfastly
determined to learn all of the wrong
lessons
and to stick to their original
assumptions and preconceived notions and
strategies no matter the results and to
that end tearful cable news
personalities mascara running down their
faces men and women
filling our leftist tears tumblers to
overflowing tried desperately to comfort
themselves by playing the greatest hits
two hits specifically and the first is
that somehow you know this is still all
about trump here's uh nicole wallace
about that on msnbc
i think we know the answer to some of
this i watched glenn younkin's
interviews on fox news and he did
nothing that claire's he did not
i mean he worshipped at the altar of
donald trump on fox news he flew an
insurrection flag at his rallies he
simply didn't he played dumb about a a
zoom rally he did not really put much
distance between himself and donald
trump on the big lie or the deadly
insurrection in which
police officers were maimed by flagpole
so
i think that the the real ominous thing
is that
critical race theory
which isn't real
turned the suburbs
15 points
to the trump
insurrection-endorsed republican what do
democrats do about that
worshiped at the altar of donald trump
he did that apparently by mentioning
trump's name like twice in a year
he didn't campaign with trump
he didn't talk about trump
youngkin treated trump as mostly
irrelevant to the concerns of virginia
voters because he is
he's the former president of the united
states parents in virginia voters in
virginia are not going about their days
thinking constantly about the former
president
worried about him longing for him
they're thinking about their own
families their kids their communities
their country
the people who think about trump the
most are leftists in politics and media
trump is the star in their solar system
they orbit around him
they don't know how to talk about
anything but him
they certainly don't know how to
campaign against anything but him that's
all mcauliffe could manage
yonkin mentioned trump like twice in a
year mcauliffe mentioned him twice per
sentence
and we see how that strategy worked out
but we'll get back to that in a minute
i'm not done reveling in the pain of my
enemies yet the the other major theme
from the media
is that virginia voters are all racist
for voting against mcauliffe who is
white by the way
i mean truly why else would a person
vote against terry mcauliffe other than
anti-black racism here's kirsten powers
on cnn
there was all of this you know talking
about critical race theory and and
representing it as if it was happening
in elementary school which of course is
not even being taught there but it's
there were a lot of these hot button
cultural issues i think
that um that that
that young king was really able to use
to his advantage um i don't think that
that's right because i think it was
misrepresented
but this this is now i think also the
republican playbook is is to use these
issues to scare people basically um a
feeling out of control you know that
that everything's out of control with
their children and they need to be
protected from these people with
demagogues and this agenda right yeah
let's be clear some of it was
dog whistle yeah right some of it was
uh dog whistle racism
that's their favorite term is dog
whistle
if you if you're even using the phrase
dog whistle this point that's a dog
whistle that you're a [ __ ] um because
dog whistle doesn't mean what they what
they think it means
uh and and for them you know this is dog
whistle racism and because it's the
republicans who are obsessed with race
they claim
joy reid on msnbc she
uh expectedly agrees
the coronavirus or the virus it was a
very
low importance to many voters
it was education right which is code for
white parents don't like the idea of
teaching about race and i mean
unfortunately
race is just the most palpable tool in
the tool kit used to be of the
democratic party back in the day when
they were dixiecrats and now of the
republican party it just is powerful
race is a palpable tool that's true i
mean nobody knows that better than joy
reid without the tool of race she'd be
working as a cashier at bath and body
works the only reason she's famous in
earning a hefty paycheck with a major
media company is that she's a black
woman who plays the race card that's the
only reason that's that's why they have
her on the payroll she has no other
insight to offer nothing else to bring
to the table have you ever heard joy
reid say anything
interesting have you ever heard him make
a point that was not about race where
you went well it's an interesting
point i mean it's all these people that
you see they they're on camera they get
paid millions of dollars to be on camera
every single day talking and they never
say anything
that's even remotely interesting
so she's got nothing else to bring to
the table race is a palpable tool all
right
and again no one knows that better than
her nia malika henderson on cnn she
knows uh too from experience that race
is a palpable tool here's her take on
the situation
i think we also see the enduring power
of the culture wars and the republicans
are better at playing this game because
it's essentially white identity politics
that works for republicans we saw it in
2016
and we're seeing it in some of these
races now particularly uh in the
mcauliffe race with the crt issue uh in
education
republicans are playing identity
politics she says
democrats and the media set half the
cities in the country on fire for six
months by convincing people that police
officers or police officers were out
hunting and killing black men and yet
republicans are the ones cynically
exploiting racial tensions and anxieties
sure thing
and yet all of this crying and panicking
still was not as embarrassing as the
reaction from mcauliffe himself who took
to the stage late in the night for a
concession speech which was noticeably
lacking in any kind of actual concession
he has since since conceded this morning
he sent out a statement conceding
um but when he gave his speech he
refused to do that and then while
leaving the stage uh we could play this
he as you can see he began dancing
uh
that's what he's that's what he is doing
and he also appears to be wearing
lipstick i don't know is it possible to
zoom in we probably can't but
it isn't he he's wearing lipstick am i
are my i know that i'm colorblind
do my eyes deceive me
or is this man not wearing lipstick he
put on lipstick and he went out and
danced on stage i mean junkin broke this
guy
either that he was maybe he was eating a
great popsicle before
giving a speech
maybe he was drowning his sorrows with
boxed wine maybe he was doing all of
those things together having the
popsicle drinking wine putting on
lipstick crying
we all have our coping mechanisms i
suppose
but all that is said extracting
ourselves from the realm of delusion
re-entering realityville what are the
actual takeaways from last night i think
there are many but um let's talk about
two one
i'm not one to gloat but we uh we moved
the needle here at the daily wire i
think our rally in loudoun county helped
to bring a national spotlight to the
education issue in virginia immobilized
people that are investigative reporting
which blew the lid off of the sexual
abuse cover-up in loudoun county schools
so we're we're making a difference here
and when i say we i don't just mean
people employed by the daily wire none
of what we're doing would make a
difference if we were just talking to
ourselves
uh this was a team effort between us and
you and the audience with a big and
unintentional assist from the loudoun
county school board we got to thank them
also none of this would have happened
without their indispensable
contributions
so i guess i lied on second thought i i
am one to gloat
as conservatives we've had plenty of
losses to sulk over so you have to
celebrate the wins too and this was a
major win and it wouldn't have happened
without us if you're a daily wire fan
even better a member you're truly a part
of of something special you're part of a
mission and we're getting results
these are results
two as i've been preaching all month and
for years before that
um the culture war matters the culture
of war
is
the war pal politics is but one
battlefield one engagement within that
broader struggle struggle
political victories and political
defeats they happen within the context
of culture
and despite what you just heard from
that cable news talking head about
republicans being good at fighting
culture wars
for a very long time the opposite has
been the case i hope that is true now
and will be even more true in the future
but historically that has not been true
republicans retreated from the culture
war and the culture itself surrendering
it piece by piece to the left
giving up on the war but hoping to
squeak out a few victories now and again
on the political battlefield
the problem with that strategy is that
even if you achieve those victories
which you will inevitably as the
political pendulum tends to swing one
way and then another
so no matter what's happening with the
culture republicans are going to win
some democrats are going to win some
but even when it swings your way the
supposedly conservative political
leaders are leading within the context
of a culture owned by the left this
means that any imprint left by a
republican president or governor will be
like a footprint in the sand during low
tide it's only going to get washed away
and soon it will be as though nobody had
walked there at all you won't be able to
tell the difference i mean look at
donald trump
nearly everything that that that he
accomplished through four years was
erased in like an hour of the biden
administration
okay joe biden was able to erase all of
that by snapping his fingers
and by his second day in office
trump it was as if trump never existed
now he still exists because they talk
about him all the time but in terms of
policies of of um
you know actual
tangible things achievements
all of that wiped away
and that's because you can't stop the
tide of culture
the only hope is to win the culture
we're still very far from achieving that
goal
but that is the goal it has to be or
else we might as well give up now i mean
if that's not the goal if the goal is
not to win the culture
then what's the point
give up
every man for yourself go flee into the
mountains flee into the forest
board the first uh elon musk rocket ship
to mars i mean
if we're giving up on the culture
so it never made any sense when you
heard these conservatives ah let's not
worry about the culture war
so you're saying let's not worry about
anything then
why are you what are we talking about
then
what do you think you're fighting for if
you're not fighting for the culture
but if you are fighting the real fight
the fight for culture it has to start
with education
and education was of course the issue
in virginia
it didn't start out that way but that's
what it became
why is education the first thing you got
to talk about when we're talking about
culture because you can have again all
of the republican elected leaders you
want if 50 million children are still
going to left-wing indoctrination camps
every day where they're subjected to
relentless social conditioning and
left-wing religious procession it's not
going to matter much in the end
so the fight for culture
which again is the fight
has to begin in the education system
and this was
hopefully what we're looking at is the
beginning of something
not not uh this is this is as much as we
can gloat
in our victories and it's fun to do
we'd make a big mistake if we said well
there we go we won that one let's move
on to the next battle
i mean if the ultimate goal
in terms of education is to retake the
education system
and to fundamentally transform it into
something where it is no longer a
left-wing indoctrination camp then there
is a lot of work still to be done
i mean essentially what we're talking
about this is this is not about re we
reform the system
this would have to be a total
dismantling of the system
and then rebuilding it into something
entirely different
those are the ultimate goals
so there's still a lot of work yet to be
done
but this is a big victory and we can
enjoy that at least for a day now let's
get to our five headlines
[Music]
well i want to tell you quickly about
one of my favorite products you hear
about you hear me talk about all the
time relief band relief band is the
number one fda cleared anti-nausea
wristband that has been clinically
proven to quickly relieve and
effectively prevent nausea and vomiting
associated with motion sickness anxiety
migraines hangovers morning sickness
chemotherapy and so much more i don't go
anywhere without my relief band if i get
into a car in uber and i forgot it i
always say hang on gotta grab my relief
ben i run back inside i put it on i'm
very proud about it i tell everybody
about my relief band and uh the product
is a 100 drug-free non-drowsy solution
and it provides all-natural long-lasting
relief with zero side effects for as
long as needed the technology was
originally developed over 20 years ago
in hospitals to relieve nausea from
patients but now the relief band it's
available to the masses how it works is
relief band stimulates a nerve in the
wrist that travels to the part of your
brain that controls nausea it feels like
magic but it's not this is pure science
and it works i can tell you that from
extensive experience relief band just
released its newest model relief band
sport the sport is waterproof features
interchangeable bands
and has extended battery life so you can
wear this even while you're playing
sports if you have a bout of nausea on
the basketball court um then you have
that relief band on and that's going to
take care of that problem instead of
puking all over the basketball court as
i have done countless times that's why
nobody ever wants to play with me
anymore as the holiday season quickly
approaches there's never been a better
time to give the great the gift of
relief and make sure your loved ones are
nausea free right now relief band has an
exclusive offer just for matt walsh
listeners if you go to relief band and
use promo code while she'll receive 20
off plus free shipping no questions
asked 30 day money back guarantee so
head to rel iefband.com
use our promo code walls for 20 off plus
free shipping so the other uh the other
thing i want to mention as well um and
this this hasn't really made it made it
into the analysis um for most of the
pundits both
on the left and right but i thought that
there was a very interesting polling
data looking at the exit polls and what
is it that motivated voters
and we know that
i mean i was looking at a chart in the
new york times that
shows shows every single
showing
which which counties were more
republican than they were
um during the presidential election or
more democrat and every single one it's
it's a it's a red arrow to the right i
mean every single county every single
county
in virginia more republican than it was
in 2020
and so you had a lot of swing voters and
even some democrats who decided not to
vote for the um
for the democrat this time around you
look at the exit poll i saw one
interesting data point 43 said they
didn't want to vote for the democrat
because they were grossed out that joe
biden's pants um
and i thought that was a really
fascinating
tidbit
and i know i said that we shouldn't be
talking about this anymore
and i still feel that way
but at the same time you know is it a is
it here's all i'm asking
it's just a question
is it a coincidence
that joe biden pants in front of the
pope
and then only a few days later democrats
lose big
in a major election
are we really going to say that's
totally coincidental and i think
education i think all these things are
important
but he did poop his pants allegedly
it's not funny
uh but
i'm just throwing it out there it's just
a question i'm asking it and then we'll
move on uh one other thing here as we as
we move on to the headlines
you know we're told that
uh glenn young can win one because of
racism and there are a lot of uh
white suprema all these all these
parents
a bunch of white supremacists and that's
why they voted for glenn young
because this this is a this is a
strategy that's really going to work
going into 2022 the midterms going and
then going into 2024.
i mean the democrats they tried calling
parents domestic terrorists
terry mcauliffe came out and said uh
parents none of your business what
happens in the schools
let the teachers decide
major backlash against that
and uh now they're simply going to
double down on it and say yeah you're a
bunch of racist white supremacists but
that's interesting because the
lieutenant governor
is a woman by the name of winsome sears
and she's a black woman
she's the first black lieutenant
governor in virginia
and this is the woman that a bunch of
white supremacist racists voted for
now she got up last night to speak and
um all those racists in the audience
they were you know oddly enough i don't
know if they all had their eyes closed
or what it was kind of dark you know i i
don't know what it is
they didn't notice that she was a black
woman because they're all cheering for
her even though they're a bunch of races
but um let's listen to a little bit of
uh winsome
sears last night
we're gonna have safer neighborhoods
safer communities
and our children are going to get a good
education
because education lifted my father out
of poverty education lifted me out of
poverty education will lift us all out
of poverty because we
we must have marketable skills so that
our children cannot just survive but
they will thrive and they will create
generational wealth
that's what this is about
[Applause]
i'm going to finish up
we love you too
it's a historic night yes it is but i
didn't run to make history i just wanted
to leave it better than i found it
you know she is actually a uh talented
and charismatic speaker
and there aren't very many of those in
the republican party um there aren't
many very many of those in politics
general or in life it's that's a it's a
rare it's a rare talent
but the republican party has been has
been really hurting for those for those
types of um politicians who can get up
there and just kind of speak and sound
natural not sound scripted and have a j
have a have a natural kind of charisma
to she really has that so i think
there's a star in the making here we'll
be seeing a lot more from winsome seers
uh who again is
beloved by the white supremacists in the
audience cheering say it's shouting they
love her
how could that be well you know here's
how it really happens is because uh the
media when when the media gets around to
acknowledging the existence of winsome
sears which they haven't done
they they right now the strategy is
we're not going to talk about this woman
at all
um
but eventually especially if she gets
more and more high profile
um
they're going to have to acknowledge her
and when they do they're going to say
well she is uh
she's technically black but really she's
a part of the
she's a part of the structures of
whiteness or whatever nonsense
so she's she's white in spirit
if not in terms of skin pigment that's
what they'll say
now all that said
of course making this a racial thing is
absurd
and it would be absurd no matter what
but especially absurd when the guy who
lost is white
um as well
but making this a racial thing is absurd
saying that it's uh you know tying this
to racism is of course completely
ridiculous
this is part of the democrat tourette
syndrome they don't it's this just it's
instinctive everything anytime something
doesn't go the way they like is racism
racism
um they can't you know they're stuck in
traffic and they're in their cars
shouting racism racism did this
all ridiculous
however
the claim that part of the story here is
quote unquote white backlash
um that's not entirely falls
there is an element of so-called white
backlash in that
it turns out
white parents
aren't really crazy about sending their
kids to school
so that they can learn that um they are
evil that they're inherently bigoted
that they are the inheritors of
generational guilt for things that they
didn't do
okay so yeah it turns out white people
aren't a lot of white people aren't
crazy about that
it turns out that a lot of white people
don't like being cast as the villains
don't like being degraded and insulted
so is that part of the story sure that's
part of it
and there's there's nothing
strange about that there's nothing
outrageous about it there's certainly
nothing racist about it
from the left perspective you know they
think
they should be able to shout at white
people say you're all a bunch of
scumbags and villains
and say you know send your kids to us
and we're going to tell them the same
thing
send your send your your scummy demon
offsprings to us
so we can tell them all about how
they're inherently racist and that
nobody can be racist against them
um
and that's somehow they have to
apologize simply for existing
all of their you know
their ancestors were all
scumbags as well or worse
so the left thinks they should tell that
they should say that to us and our
response should be okay yes
yes sir
yes ma'am however you identify
and we bow our heads in shame and go
along and if and if we dare say you know
what i'm not no i'm not crazy about that
i don't agree
then they start shouting white backlash
the white people are upset
well yeah
yes
you're correct about that part of it
all right next the daily mail has an
exclusive interview with the mother of
the teen boy in loudoun county who raped
the girl in the bathroom obviously a
story that
was pivotal i think in this election
and in the overall movement to reclaim
our education system
but we haven't heard from anyone in this
boy's family until now the daily mail
tracked this this woman down
and let me read a little bit
about what she had to say and she's
she's defending her her son and claiming
that this has all been twisted and blown
out of proportion everything but here's
here's some of what she says
says the mother of the 15 year old boy
who dressed in a skirt and raped a
female classmate in the girls bathroom
and was then charged with sexually
assaulting another girl months later
says her son doesn't identify as a
female and it wasn't just some disguise
to slip into the girl's bathroom
speaking exclusively with daily mail the
mother who asked not to be identified
for the sake of her underage son
defended his actions as that of a
heterosexual hormonal teen who in the
case of the rape had consensual sex with
the girl twice before
totally irrelevant to the question of
whether or not this was rape
which which she has been found guilty of
by the way
she declared quote he's a 15 year old
boy that wanted to have sex in the
bathroom with somebody that was willing
and they're just twisting this just
enough to make it a political hot button
issue what a lovely woman this mother is
well he he wanted to have sex with
someone who was willing but she wasn't
willing it turned out and so he did it
anyway
can you blame the poor boy
that's what we're getting for the mother
the story exploded when scott smith the
father of the rape victim victim was
dragged out of a school board meeting
with a bloody mouth on june 22nd so we
know about that background um
getting a little bit more from
the mother
says despite his androgynous style and
declaration that he's pansexual the
boy's mother insisted he isn't the
gender fluid boogeyman in a culture war
about transgender policies
she explained he would wear a skirt one
day and then the next day he would wear
jeans and a t-shirt a polo or hoodie he
was trying to find himself and that
involved all kinds of styles
i believe he was doing it because it
gave him attention that he desperately
needed and sought
at the same time she concedes her son is
deeply troubled acknowledging his
extensive history of misbehavior that
included sending nude photos of himself
to a girl in fifth grade
she uh doesn't clarify if this is
something he did in fifth grade or he
sent
i assume from from what she's saying
that in fifth grade he did this i'm not
sure
um she reached her own breaking point
with him in early october when he phoned
her from the juvenile detention center
following his second arrest
the mom says he asked me how i was doing
and i said i'm broken i'm shattered you
shattered me do you have any idea what
you've done to me what you've done to
your family and his response was no what
did i do
she said that his uh she had been his
primary point of contact with his dad
living in new jersey
at that point i was like you know what i
love you i always will i'll do
everything i can to always be there for
you in any capacity possible but i told
them you need to call your father from
now on do not call me i need to heal and
i need you to figure this out for
yourself
and she goes on to talk about how the
father showed up to the juvenile court
appearance
um
and uh and she was upset about that and
she gets more into the family drama
and a lot of details we don't we don't
really need isn't isn't relevant
um
i think there are there are a few things
here to point out
the first is that
nobody ever claimed certainly the daily
wire in our investigative reporting we
never claimed that the boy was
transgender
we said he was wearing a skirt on the
day of the assault which is true
and in terms of how he identifies
how we never said anything about that
it doesn't doesn't matter it doesn't
make up doesn't make a difference
so he identifies as pansexual or gender
fluid or whatever according to her
changes by the day he's trying to find
himself
uh she says
and apparently raping a girl in the
bathroom was part of his journey of
self-discovery from the way that she's
putting it
but that's that's not relevant at all
that's not the point
you know
how does this tie into the uh
to the bathroom policies the transgender
bathroom policies
how do we make this connection
well we didn't make that connection
i didn't the daily wire didn't
that wasn't in in the investigative
reporting on this
you know who made the connection the
loudoun county school board they're the
ones who did it
because they lied about this and tried
to cover it up and they did that because
at the same time
when this was all happening they were
trying to push through
uh the transgender bathroom policies to
allow boys into the girls room
so they are the ones who said well gee
uh we really want to pass this
transgender policy
and the fact that a girl was just
brutally raped inside of one of our
bathrooms is pretty inconvenient to that
even if the boy didn't identify as
transgender so we're going to pretend it
never happened and we're going to lie
right to the face of the father of the
victim
and then when he gets arrested for
reacting in an angry way like any father
would we're gonna paint them as a
domestic terrorist
so they're the ones who drew this
connection
is does
is is this assault related to the
bathroom policies yes because the
loudoun county school board made it that
way
because a big part of the scandal here
you know
a terrible thing happening at a school
you know someone falling victim to a
terrible violent crime
that is
a terrible crime
it's not it does it's not immediately an
institutional scandal the institutional
scandal happens with the cover-up
and they did the cover-up because of the
bathroom policies that's how it all ties
together
and also it's related in another way
that
you know even if the bathroom policies
were not the reason why that boy was in
the bathroom
this event in the bathroom only
illustrates for those who need it
illustrated
why it's a really bad idea to combine
boys and girls in bathrooms no matter
how they identify
doesn't make a difference because no
matter how a boy identifies he's still a
boy
biologically and he doesn't belong in a
bathroom with with girls
nothing good can come of it
this is about what we saw in lounge
county is is like the worst case
scenario that can come from it and it
will happen more
it's just a matter of statistics
this this is mathematics here
the more you combine boys and girls in
high schools and bathrooms
the more likely the more opportunities
there are for
sexual assaults
so this is this is an example as to why
uh it's a bad idea to combine them in
that way
and there's something else too you know
the other thing we take from this is
that this boy
um by the mother's
admission came from a chaotic home life
father not in the home
i could have told you that
you know i mean i that that's that's
something
not knowing anything about this boy at
all
only knowing what he did only knowing
that he's wearing a skirt
and that he raped a girl i could have
told you right then and there he doesn't
have a father in the house
in fact i could have told you that
without without even the rape
the boy wearing the skirt
pretty good indication there's no father
in the home
and even if he's in the home he's not
present
he's not a real influence in the home
combine those two things together and
yeah it's almost certain the father's
not there and he's not
so he comes from a chaotic
home home life with with no guidance i
mean the mother's talking about he's
trying to find himself he's gender fluid
one day he's pansexual next he's wearing
a skirt he's wearing jeans he's wearing
a hoodie whatever
he he's he's begging for attention
trying to find himself yeah well that's
where that's where you need a parent
especially a father if this is a boy
we're talking about
you need a father there to say son
this isn't what boys do
okay you're a boy
here's how boys are supposed to act boys
don't wear skirts
okay this is not what boys do
boys don't this isn't how boys dress
that's not how boys behave
you need a father there to
impart those kinds of lessons and if
he's not there or even if he is there
but he refuses to impart those lessons
then it's not going to head anywhere
good and that's that's what we saw here
all right next the kyle rittenhouse
trial has started the uh prosecution
made its opening statement which is that
you know the the prosecution their their
opening argument their their their point
here is that kyle rittenhouse was there
and that he killed some guys
and nobody disputes that but that's
basically their whole case he was there
and he killed people
uh right
no one denies that
the question is why
did he kill those people um was it
self-defense or not and that's and
that's the defense's argument as
presented in their in their opening
arguments and as they'll lay out you
know as the case
proceeds
their argument is that there's video
and you can watch the video and so we
know exactly what happened and the video
conclusively proves that kyle
rittenhouse was defending himself he was
being attacked
by violent murderous crazed mobs of
people
and uh he had no choice but to defend
himself and on that end human events
obtained never-before-seen footage
um
somehow we have never seen this footage
before this is apparently from i guess
an fbi surveillance drone
which was there on that night and the
fbi has had this footage and we have not
seen it until now
but let's uh let's play this this
footage here so actually before we play
it so this is
there were there were two
incidents two shootings
um
this is the first one where rosenbaum
was was shot
and so it's a little bit hard to see
what's going on here but you see if
you're watching this this video you can
see on the top left corner
um rosenbaum
is
kyle rittenhouse and let's play the
video now
so the top left corner
you see rosenbaum and
britton house
greenhouse is running away rosa mom's
pursuing him
at the very last minute
you can see kyle rittenhouse is forced
to turn around and fire
in fact there was
rosa and that we hadn't seen we had seen
in in the previous all the other footage
we'd seen so far it was rosenbaum
pursuing
ridden house so we knew that was
happening but then from the from the
vantage point of the video evidence we
had up until this point uh they went
behind some cars and then we hear
gunshots ring out and we don't know
exactly what happened
and so you could speculate well maybe
uh maybe rosenbaum gave up and stopped
and put his hands up he said never mind
i'm not going to hurt you
you could speculate about that or claim
that well now we see it on video
he was pursuing him
he he and he had stated his intention he
wanted to kill this guy
rittenhouse tried to get away rosa bomb
was
gaining ground at the very last minute
he turned around and shot
while being pursued
rosenbaum didn't give up didn't try to
walk away and get shot in the back while
he's walking away that didn't happen
um so this is and then and then in the
other video footage that we've seen of
the second uh shooting that that's could
couldn't be more clear
and in both cases what you have
is kyle rittenhouse
trying to get away
he's trying to run away
they're coming after him
and they have through their behavior and
their own words they've made very clear
what their intentions are
and only at the last minute does kyle
ridden house open fire
because the other option would have been
okay let this mob these violent people
descend upon me and just hope they don't
kill me
i know some of them are armed um
you know
even if they're not they could still do
great damage to me they could even kill
me they could take my gun and shoot me
with it like you know the only other
option was either pull the trigger or
not and let them descend upon you and
just hope that the damage they inflict
on you isn't too severe
but you are not legally required to take
that kind of risk
all right let's see one
i've got a bunch of other things i
haven't even talked about yet uh
i do have to mention this case though
this is from nbc it says a washington
state father killed his daughter's 19
year old boyfriend for selling her into
a sex trafficking ring according to
police
the boyfriend's remains were discovered
in the trunk of an abandoned car on east
everett avenue in spokane last month
police said in a press conference
investigators believe the victim was
killed in november 2020. the girl's
father joe john eisenmann 60 was charged
with first-degree murders being held on
a million dollars bail
um so police said that eisenmann learned
in october 2020 that his juvenile
daughter had been sex trafficked in the
seattle area and obtained information
that her boyfriend was responsible
according to the press release eisenmann
was able to rescue his daughter and get
her back to uh her her home
that same month when the father learned
that his daughter's boyfriend was going
to be at a location in airway heights
eisenmann drove there and waited for the
19 year old to arrive
during that encounter eisenmann abducted
the victim tying him up and placing him
in the trunk of a vehicle eisenmann
subsequently assaulted the victim by
hitting him in the head with a cinder
block and then stabbed him repeatedly
causing his death
after the homicide eisenman drove the
vehicle to a remote area and abandoned
the car with the body still inside
unironically
this is uh father of the year i wish i
put me on that jury and i will sentence
him to a round of applause and free beer
for life
and um
i say that without any hint of irony
whatsoever assuming everything we just
heard is true i mean assuming these
details are all accurate
it's possible that they're not but on
the assumption that that this is all
true
um
i i would certainly hope that there's no
[Music]
jury in america even in washington state
that would convict this man and send him
to prison
i mean they might they might feel like
they have to convict them of something
you know slap on the wrist at worst
that naughty naughty don't do that next
time
send him on his way
but in reality this is this is a
according to the details this is a good
father doing what a father should do
and doing what you know what most
fathers probably wouldn't do or a great
many fathers wouldn't but not because
they have a moral problem with it just
because they're worried you know they're
worried about their own livelihood and
they don't want to go to jail
but i tell you one thing for sure
any father
if if their daughter is is sex
trafficked
any father would want to track down the
sex trafficker and kill him
and any any father would feel and would
be totally justified in doing so it's
just that if they wouldn't it's just
because they don't want to go to prison
which is you know which is not a
not an irrational
concern either
we think about what this guy did
according to the report this is from the
police
it's not even the defense attorney
making this claim this is the police
saying
that his daughter
was
made into a sex slave
he goes and rescues him her from sex
slavery
gets her to safety
finds out who did it
tracks the guy down
beats him with a cinder block and stabs
him to death
this is they they literally made a movie
about that that's liam neeson and taken
and yeah that's just a movie but if
you've see it like nobody watches that
movie everyone you watch that movie
you're rooting for liam neeson
i feel the same way about it here um
that's
that is the correct fatherly response
to your daughter being sex trafficked
and the world is a better place today
without that scumbag with him stabbed to
death and stuffed in a trunk the world
is a much better place so
congratulations to that man
and uh
i hope he has a you know
uh i hope his father's day gift next
year is is getting off on all charges
because that's what he deserves all
right now let's get to our comment
section
who's rocking polka dot and flannel
shirts without shame
do you know their name
they're the sweet baby gang
yeah i did call this segment the comment
section not reading the comments anymore
so that's slight see that's that's the
branding
genius that sets this show apart from
all others that slight tweak there
most people wouldn't think of that
called the comment section instead we
had seven three hour sessions with
marketing to come up with that change
okay
all right 420 snack time says matt is a
fishing enthusiast yet complains like a
chick that baseball is boring why am i
not surprised a skinny jean-wearing
hipster like matt dislikes a classic
american sport like baseball well you're
banned for that obviously
um but also phishing is not a spectator
sport okay
well that's not true i actually do sit
and watch people i'll watch youtube
videos of people fishing for two hours
so uh but but so i have to abandon that
line of logic and i'm just going to move
on to the next comment you're still
banned from the show though
not getting out of this
joseph says matt my local pizza place in
pennsylvania promises that they'll
deliver in 45 minutes and routinely
comes in 20. i think you're stretching
to make a point the issue is right but
you move to the middle of nowhere
tennessee suck it up
joseph i live in nashville
you're a band from the show too
we're on a roll today guys
you all want to get banned is that what
you want
david says i like baseball more than
football because i prefer my sports to
not stop every 8 seconds for 30 seconds
while people adjust themselves by 5
yards and try the exact same thing over
and over again i also like baseball more
than basketball because a good defense
should be to be able to prevent a bad
offense from scoring
plus unlike sports with timers every
play in baseball in a baseball game
matters
each player can make a difference and
most of all you don't have to memorize
18 000 different fouls and keep track of
40 moving objects just to understand why
everybody
stopped playing but the timer is still
going so what i what i take from this
david is that uh much like a woman you
you have a
you you're not able to understand the
football game as you're watching
uh maybe you've never sat
and watched a football game with another
man who can explain it to you
and uh
and i understand that because you will
you know no man wants to explain the
game of football to another man while
he's trying to watch football so i think
that's the situation you're in but it's
in in in terms of the game not stopping
are you kidding me baseball
the whole game is a stoppage like the
whole game is stopped all the time
yeah football is less exciting in
between the plays
okay but in baseball that's the whole
game
the whole game is is is about as
exciting as the moment in between plays
on a football field
so you're banned from the show too
uh
david another david says
as a former addict of the worst kind i
get sick of hearing addiction is not a
choice it's a disease
we've all known since elementary school
that doing drugs is addictive and we
shouldn't do it and yet every day people
choose to do them for the first time the
second time the third time 20th time and
so on so yes you choose addiction and if
you truly want to stop you will
it'll be one of the hardest things
you've ever done and you you will
struggle and stumble but if you truly
want to change your will people do it
every single day and they'll continue to
do so while others continue to to choose
drugs
um yeah i largely agree with you david
and that's why i also don't like this um
you know i i've i've talked many times
about
the diseasification of human behavior
um turning every
you know every every destructive human
behave behavior into the symptom of a
disease
every difficult human emotion becomes a
disease everything is medicalized and so
we do the same thing with addiction we
say it's a disease um
and and maybe if you want to just if you
want to define the word disease in a
very broad way i mean you could find a
way to define the word disease where
addiction would qualify but then the
word disease really doesn't mean
anything anymore
um
and yeah that's it's also an important
point that
yeah no one wakes up one day and says i
want to be addicted to drugs and then
goes out and tries to become addicted
nobody does that
just like
there are many morbidly obese people out
there but nobody says i want to be
morbidly obese and i'm going to go
pursue that
there might be some weirdos who you know
who have tick-tock accounts or something
that that do operate that way but for
the most part no
so you don't choose obesity in that
sense
but you do choose the behavior
that you know will cause obesity and so
it is a choice in that sense
which is really the only sense that
matters
and yes we could say the same thing with
addiction
you don't
your choice was not you were not
pursuing addiction but you did engage in
a behavior that you knew would very
likely cause addiction
that is an important point okay um
daryl says matt as much as i like you
and michael knows i can't help but think
that all the daily wires just controlled
opposition ben shapiro feels like a vax
pushing traitor he probably hangs with
hillary clinton or bill gates
you're actually
right about this i'm not supposed to
talk about it
uh but uh ben and hillary are i mean
they're best friends
every time i see ben all he ever does is
blab about hanging out with hillary
oh me and hillary went mini golfing
yesterday it was so fun
he doesn't shut up about it i mean
they're best friends she's she's here
hillary clinton's here in the office a
lot in fact hanging out um so it yeah it
is kind of an uncomfortable and awkward
situation i'm glad that you pointed that
out
uh let's see
finally do we have a finale
okay eric says unfortunately i don't
expect any supreme court will ever
overthrow roe v wade no matter how many
conservative justices are the
are um
are on the supreme court regarding
kavanaugh and barrett because of the
major controversies surrounding their
nominations i really think they're going
out of their way to appear as if they
aren't trump's lackeys and aren't
conservative ideologues
unfortunately the justices appointed by
democrats never seem to worry about how
they're viewed i pray that kavanaugh and
barrett will eventually start acting
like conservatives justice roberts is
beyond a lost cause he's a full-blown
liberal
um
yeah well the thing is with kavanaugh
you know
if you looked at his judicial record to
find out that he's that he's a
that he's leans more liberal you know
left of of center that's not terribly
shocking with barrett
there were red flags i mean there were
indications
but i was
certainly fooled
i mean overall it is it is a
surprising turn of events
and you would hope the whole idea
between
behind having supreme court justices
with lifetime appointments is that
they're not swayed by politics
they're not running for reelection
they're going to be in that position for
the rest of their lives if they want to
be
they don't need to worry about getting a
job somewhere else
and so they're supposed to look at cases
and make the right decision without any
political concerns whatsoever because
who cares what the public thinks you're
not subject to them you're not you're
not up this isn't up for a vote
there there are doubt there are plenty
of downsides to that arrangement to the
lifetime appointment arrangement
this is supposed to be the major upside
but as you point out
that upside has evaporated
because it does seem as though roberts
kavanaugh even barrett now
um they are very concerned about how
they're viewed it is it is as if they
are running for office
so the whole idea behind lifetime
appointment has been basically negated
i'm very excited to introduce an
incredible app that everyone who buys
gas needs to know about and that's
that's pretty much everybody probably
listening right now it's called get
upside my listeners are making up to 25
cents for every gallon of gas every time
they fill up just download the free get
upside app in the app store or google
play right now use promo code walsh and
get a bonus 25 cents per gallon on your
first fill up that's up to 50 cents back
that you're getting this is free money
and if you like what what do i have to
say to get to convince you to take some
free money takes almost no effort and uh
you're getting that money back to you
just download the app for free use promo
code walsh to get up to 50 cents a
gallon cashback on your first tank some
people who drive a lot are making as
much as two to three hundred dollars a
month in cash back and there's no catch
the cash back gets added right to your
account you can cash out any time to
your bank account paypal e-gift card for
amazon and other brands again no no cash
there's there's no fine print here it's
very very simple just download the free
get upside app and use promo code walsh
to get up to 50 cents per gallon cash
back on your first tank that's codewalsh
with the get upside app get it now
and also i got to tell you about this if
you've been searching for a daily
morning podcast without an agenda look
no further than the morning wire which
has been topping the apple and spotify
charts since its recent release it's the
only daily news podcast that values your
time and the truth and while we're
working overtime to bring you the news
you need to know we need your help to
keep the facts trending towards number
one so subscribe now and start listening
to morningwire and applespotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts and
leave a five star review if you like
what you hear now let's get to our daily
cancellation
today we have another reverse
cancellation we'll once again be
canceling the outrage mob except for a
change of pace i am not the target of
the mob that's getting canceled instead
a few days ago the social media masses
were very upset a conservative
commentator and radio host jesse kelly
who while discussing his approach to
parenting tweeted this he says my sons
are both getting excited about uh are
getting kicked out of my home when they
graduate high school they know this i've
told them their whole lives go fly a
little birdie it's my job to make sure
they know how
so he's kicking his sons out of his home
once they're legal adults now plenty on
the left developed
severe tummy aches over this and they
responded with angry comments calling
him a terrible and mean father
explaining why it's a parent's
responsibility to care for their poor
helpless children well into adult
adulthood if need be and i'm sure many
of the commenter commenters were
themselves
are themselves helpless children in
their mid-20s or 30s who still rely on
mommy and daddy for room and board and
to buy them lunchables and juice boxes
but the far more fascinating reaction
came from some on the right
who also criticized kelly's parenting
plan but from a slightly different angle
now they're not part of the outrage mob
but i'm going to focus more on them
instead because they're more interesting
so rabamari well-known conservative
writer and author was one of the people
to take issue with this he responded and
said quote
when i was younger i disdained the
intergenerational living that was a part
of my
of even my uber westernized family's
ethos i struck out on my own as quickly
as i could now at 36 i see that the
iranian ethos as a treasure for the
young the middle aged and elderly
now many other responses were along this
line arguing that it's actually a
traditional
and family-first mentality which
encourages adult children to stay at
home with their parents thus they would
say the most conservative thing is to
support this setup
it's actually a leftist view to turn
your nose up at the proverbial adult
living in his parents basement that's
what they argue
and they're correct that throughout
history this has been the standard
approach
still is in many cultures
but this comparison ignores some major
differences between the typical adult
living at home in america in 2021 and
the historical version of the same
arrangement
two big ones to consider
first historically a man may have stayed
with his parents until marriage
but he also got married much younger in
1950 the average age of marriage for a
man was 22.
now it's 30. that's that's a that's a
difference of nearly a decade
that's a difference of your entire 20s
just about
second historically men were learning
basic survival skills
and how to be a provider while living at
home
they were not only learning those skills
but they were applying them
part of the reason that families stayed
together through multiple generations is
that they needed all those hands on deck
to keep the household running keep food
on the table logs in the fireplace and
so on
that's not often the case now these days
young adults tend to whittle away their
20s on selfish pursuits saving money so
they can blow it on consumer electronics
or whatever other toys they enjoy
they aren't working in the fields or
chopping wood not in the vast majority
of cases anyway
young adults aren't staying at home
working hard for their families learning
and developing their survival skills
while preparing to get married sometime
before their 25th birthday instead often
they're at home drifting aimlessly
spending lots of time staring at various
screens that their parents paid for
developing no survival skills at all no
skills of any kind
until one day when they're approaching
middle age
they finally stumble into marriage or or
maybe not maybe they never do
the intergenerational setup in our
culture has helped to create an extended
nearly eternal adolescence
but historically that wasn't a problem
in fact historically there was no
extended adolescence because there was
no adolescence at all
adolescence itself is a modern invention
there's a reason why most major
religions have their coming into
adulthood their coming-of-age induction
ceremonies at the age of 13 or 15 or 16.
same for tribal societies
you know they all have this
coming-of-age moment and it's it's
it's in the teenage years
that's because a child didn't transition
slowly into adulthood historically but
instead went right from childhood to
adulthood
there were two categories of people
adults and children not three
children adolescents and adults
so that back then
a 22 year old man living at home with
his parents was indeed a man and had
been for almost a decade already
that's just not how it works anymore in
this country not in most cases
if it's different for you and your
family if you actually do have your boys
out working the fields and chopping the
wood then more power to you
but the average western family in modern
times lives a far easier and more
painless existence and they have a lot
less to do as most of the hard things
have become
mechanized and automated
what this means is that if you want your
children especially your boys to learn
how to survive in the world to develop
real skills to eventually become
competent providers it's often necessary
to kick them out of your comfortable
little nest and have them go build their
own
now it's not like you're dropping them
out of a helicopter into the amazon with
nothing but a machete and a single jug
of water
you're just sending them to go live in a
studio apartment across town or wherever
this might be the only way for them to
learn the kinds of lessons that young
men of earlier area eras learned at much
younger ages
there are many facets to adult life
in the modern world
that you can't really understand or know
how to navigate until they become a part
of your life
so you could talk to your kids about
what it's like to pay bills balance a
budget prioritize uh spending and all
that you can talk to them about any of
that
while they're still suckling from the
metaphorical teat but it's not likely to
sink in unless they're forced to do it
themselves
the fact is that we live in a culture
populated by millions of terminally
incompetent helpless childish men
who in terms of life skills are barely
above potty training level and that's
because for them
life skills have been at best a
theoretical concept
but you can't develop a skill in theory
nobody ever became a great pitcher by
reading books about it you have to pick
up the ball and start throwing it
and and the modern man isn't going to
learn how to be a man while sitting on a
beanbag chair and playing call of duty
in his you know in his parents basement
on his parents tv
he's got to go out and live it whether
he wants to or not
i had to go through that learning curve
myself it wasn't easy
i had to learn most of the lessons the
hard way apparently you know one lesson
i learned is that if you don't pay your
electric bill they'll cut off your
electricity and you're going to have
some very cold nights in january and if
you don't save money from each paycheck
and then a big expense hits that you
weren't expecting like a car you know
you have a car problem or something you
might be living off of hot dogs and
ramen noodles for a while
and you're gonna be pretty hungry
i learned all that and much more now i
provide for a family of six and they
don't go hungry and they don't freeze at
night
i did so they don't have to
until the time comes for them to go out
into the big scary world and confront
the same harsh realities that i did
that's the way it goes now it has to go
that way
unless we want to revert back to an
agrarian society you know work in the
fields and milk in the cows not a
terrible plan actually but in the
meantime if we're not doing that you'll
probably have to force your kids to
become adults the hard way
and so today jesse kelly is not
cancelled his cancellers are canceled
and if they were my kids they'd all be
said to send to bed without dinner
tonight
and tomorrow they'd be out looking for
new lodging arrangements
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pablo vadasky the
show is edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by cherokee heart
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 2021
glenn yunken the republican candidate
wins the governorship in virginia
ron desantis rightly bullies woke
businesses and amy barrett blows it on
an important supreme court case check it
out on the michael knowles show